aux archives aujourd'hui vont rappeler
des souvenirs à certains et seront
peut-être une découverte pour les plus
jeunes
à une certaine époque beaucoup de bois
coupé en forêt étaient transportés non
pas par camion mais par flottage c'est
ce qu'on appelait la drave une activité
indissociable de l'histoire de la
mauricie
[Musique]
temps
sujet dean à votre métier de trader est
ce que vous l'avez fait toujours dans la
région j'ai commencé à l'âge de 15 ans
la première de là que j'ai fait que les
fêtes à wenzhou en équilibre sur les bio
les draveurs se servait d'une longue
pique pour diriger le bois est brisé les
embâcles dans les eaux glaciales les
accidents n'étaient pas rares c'est un
métier musée maison et je te paye un
hors jeu ça paye à vous rendre avait moi
la première heure avant une pièce par
berne avant de placer 10 ça paye un peu
plus que sur venus williams heures et
d'avoir un salaire de millionnaire
[Musique]
la drave a débuté au milieu des années
1800 sur le saint maurice en 1973
l'année du reportage 40 % du bois de la
région étaient toujours acheminés
jusqu'aux usines par flottage et
l'abandon de la drave semblait difficile
à imaginer
est ce que vous me dites la date vous
l'année avec elle le flottage
complètement disparu parce qu'il faut
pas penser une roue québec étant donné
que présentement son abolition le
flottage après une augmentation de coût
de 8 à 10 dollars le coût net faut pas
penser d'abandon de flotteurs au québec
à côte la draf commencé dès que la glace
était parti au printemps et se
poursuivent et jusqu'aux gelées
d'automne pour l'industrie les avantages
étaient nombreux le bois arriver aux
usines de pâtes et papiers déjà ramolli
et presque sans écorces et cette
pratique ne faisait pas que des heureux
l'impression générale que les compagnies
papetières prennent beaucoup de place
avec leurs bois sur la centrale
combien je suis obligé d'admettre le
fait qu' on prend beaucoup d'espoir sur
les cours d'eau et que nous sommes une
nuisance pour les propriétaires de
bateaux de plaisance
malgré qu'on essaie de diminuer ses
inconvénients le plus possible mais si
nous n'avions pas la dre il faudrait
trouver une alternative l'alternative
savez de quel transporté dans un camion
cette masse de bois se prendrait des
lézards une armée de camions qui
suivrait jour et nuit
alors au lieu de polluer le fleuve on
pollue ray novak
à l'époque le ministère de
l'environnement du québec n'avait pas
encore été créé il faudra attendre 1979
pour cela mais les impacts du flottage
commencé à faire la manchette
même s'il était rapidement balayé du
revers de la main bon je pense que si je
me mets dans la peau d'un citoyen de la
mauricie caen 6 voiles de flatteurs en
passant de l'économie de la mauricie
c'est l'économie axé sur fauré ont des
papiers à est évident que les gens y
voient là dont une paix pour un c'est
pas moi quelqu'un de montréal ou à une
grande responsabilité ou les alarmistes
qui voit dans ce total quelque chose de
nettement pollution et le web d'une
façon encore plus théorique parce que
pour la modifier ses 120 ans une pet
c'est sa vie c'est la ville de sierre la
population qu'il y as of la taz les
personnes discipline ada coin je peux
dire que l'on n'est pas la veille des
tracteurs pour ce qui regarde le qatar
[Musique]
mais pour les écologistes de la première
heure il était impératif de libérer les
cours d'eau de cette chape de bois placé
l'arrivée ça marche c'est justement une
des rivières qui a probablement été le
jury tarder au québec et qu'il est
encore le travail du bois évidemment
c'est économiquement important c'est
important parce que justement des
industries du papier très importante au
québec
c'est important aussi économiquement
parce que ça lui donne beaucoup les
coûts d'opération les problèmes qui se
posent aujourd'hui
je suis à du travail je sais que nous
voulons guerre on en a besoin pour autre
chose parce que si vous devez vous
utilisez une raideur à des fins presque
exclusive à ce moment alors est ce que
c'est le pollue mais ça peut lui
évidemment que ça pollue pas c'est que
sur le savoir et je pense qu'il ya un ou
deux ans on est au moment de l'hymne
mentalité massive de poissons on savait
que le bois en coupe toutes les rivières
sans faille tout d'abord la libération
de ceux de se produire parce que les
contacts entre la surface de l'eau et
l'oxygène de l'atmosphère est une
aération qui dans nos points de vie
voilà si vous recouvrez l'arrivée
complètement de voie et puits d'aération
deuxièmement il ya tous les dépôts de
les corses l'ebit se frappent les unes
sur les autres que les causes qui dépose
sur le lit de la rivière soulier d
épaisseur assez phénoménale des corps
sur le lit de la rivière sassard
trouvera également les frères se
retrouvent tous les insectes
enfin on retrouve à détruire un peu la
vie pour la dernière idée en terminant
monsieur le sauteur je trouve un peu
sévère ben disons que ça compense pour
la peut-être le manque de sévérité qu on
a toujours eu dans le passé qui nous a
mené la pollution fait dégradation de la
nature
enfin aujourd'hui la science démontrera
que les résidus des corses accumulés au
fond de l'eau l'ibère d'importantes
quantités de mercure qui polluent l'eau
et contaminent les poissons le saint
maurice sera la dernière rivière de la
province où l'on pratiquera le flottage
l'adra vie a pris fin en 1995